listen who knows at this point there
aren't many details from people her
manager her agents and the more lawyers
so we need to hear more credible sources
but this thing is the one thing about
Brittany that's always broken my heart
about her is is that she was working
from a very very young child she was on
Broadway like ten or something
ridiculous and she's worked her entire
life she has kept her in Tyre and
managers father I mean nobody X you know
she keeps everybody nobody works for her
for free they work because they get a
percentage of what she earns so when
there's a lot of money involved nothing
would surprise me I know nothing nothing
would surprise me when she was you know
the big incident where she shaved dolls
you know those hair often all of that
it's like you know she should have taken
five years off then yeah and you know
she's back out they keep putting her
back it's time for her to have a life
and maybe her dad can find a job
I was reading the free Brittany hashtag
on Twitter and if you follow it there's
just some really disturbing things like
since 2008 and 2009 there's been a lot
of problems where she was trying to get
out of the conservative ship with her
father and it seems like she's been
trying to do that for a while and some
of the dancers were like quitting the
tour's because there was all this drug
testing going on and I guess there was
this this ominous presence sort of like
kind of keeping her down and sort of
watching over everything but what's good
about this this freed Brittany campaign
that's out and I love that sure it's
bringing awareness so that if something
shady is happening something not right
then at least now eyeballs are gonna
start heading in that direction and
we're all gonna play like Sherlock
Holmes and figure out what's going on so
we wish Brittany is okay you know I am
wearing this shirt because we all love
her I like Brittany is I've always been
a Britney fan and um you know I want her
to I want her to begin to help she's
getting but not under the rest like you
know unless because we don't know
anything no we don't know anything but
like you said that hopefully this is
putting the right eyeballs on it if God
forbid anything wrong is happening in
like we are doing right or herself with
you sure and it's like until these
people speak out around her yeah how can
you know but the extra eyeballs are
helpful because whatever place is
holding her they have to have a pretty
damn good reason to hold her now with
all this scrutiny and if they do that
wall to doctors and a judge to keep
anybody in to doctors and a judge is
what it takes to keep somebody in the
facility I'm sure it is they will have
to go to court a judge has to say yes
I'm sure you can't just say to anybody
any room like she's crazy Locker up
[Applause]
we like having five people at the table
what we did a pull do you think Britney
Spears is being held against her will
and actually only 27% of our viewers say
yes and 73% say no so there you go
[Applause]
[Music]